hi everyone okay let's start to 21 the
second lecture or the second week
um of this quarter so
um yeah hi i'm dorsa uh you saw me last
time i'm co-teaching this class with
percy um and today our plan is to talk a
little bit about robotics so this is
this is going to be kind of an informal
introduction to robotics a little bit of
a history a little bit of state of the
art
some cool videos um and and a bit of
chat so i don't need to finish my slides
i have a lot of slides i'm probably not
going to finish my slides so feel free
to interrupt me any point in time if you
have questions about anything we can
make this an informal discussion again
at any point in time uh i will probably
not cover like all the things that are
in the slides anyways
um all right so let's get into some
quick logistics
all right so
this was
our plan for the class i'm sure you've
seen this from the last lecture so the
plan was to start with reflex based
models we've kind of already started
that so
percy basically went over uh the machine
learning components last week and we
also have another week of machine
learning a little bit of deep learning
and then starting next week uh we are
going to talk about state-based models
so i'm going to cover a lot of that so
we're going to do search mdps games i'm
going to reuse a lot of videos from last
year just giving you a heads up we'll
probably add and remove some but last
year's videos there in nvidia we have a
whiteboard everything is great so i'll
probably reuse a lot of that but we
basically will plan to break them into
modules
um and then percy will cover variable
based models and i will finish logic and
finish the class so so that was just a
quick overview of what the plan is if
you remember monday lectures are not
modules right monday lectures are going
to be guest talks and chats and having
fun so um just to give you an idea of
the monday lectures um
so this is a tentative schedule you've
already done the introduction to ai
percy did that
today i will be doing this talk on state
of robotics talking a little bit about
what that is why you should care about
it
and then next week we have next monday
we have a guest speaker um and the guest
speaker is mariano florentino spoiler he
is a faculty in the law school
he's also on the california supreme
court so it should be a fun talk to
attend he does a lot of work around ai
and law he does teach a class actually
on regulating ai and he has a lot of
interesting opinions on that so totally
recommend showing up for that i think
that would be a lot of fun
then the week after we have tatsu
hashimato so tatsu is a new faculty in
the cs department he does a lot of work
around robust machine learning so he'll
probably be talking about that
followed by percy talking about state of
natural language processing in week five
by the way this is tentative so do not
quote me on that some of these dates
might change i think the speakers are
accurate the dates might move around
and then finally in week six we have we
have emma pearson talking about ai and
equality and healthcare uh she she's got
she'll be a faculty at cornell tech
joining next year so it would be
interesting to hear
hear from her
and then week seven is kind of like a
fun chat just with percy and i will show
up and you can ask us anything basically
um we plan to think about like grad
school and talk about like those topics
probably so if you have any questions
about that research what to do after 221
i think that's a good week to attend
uh week eight we have you offshore so he
was faculty at stanford and he has done
a lot of work like from back in the days
in ai and his you know kind of like all
the revolution of ai so really fun to
show up for his talk
and then week nine we have drago and
golovk so drago is the head of
autonomous driving at waymo uh so if
you're interested in learning about
autonomous driving to the extent that he
can talk about it
that would be weakness
um and then week 10 i will do a
conclusion so um that is and i'll wrap
up the class so so that is kind of our
plan from one day lectures i just want
to advertise it so and you kind of like
have a plan of what will show up next
um next couple weeks okay
all right any questions
if you have any questions by the way um
just put it on chat or interrupt
all right so today we want to talk about
robotics um and i just wanted to start
it off i have a lot of videos today so
it'll be fun videos i just wanted to
start off by some video showing robots
can dance just to advertise this
[Music]
you guys can hear this right
yeah okay
[Music]
[Music]
anyways i wanted to start with this
video just to motivate why we care about
robotics this is spot from boston
dynamics boston dynamics is this company
that does a lot of really cool robotics
type of work we'll see more of the
robots later in this lecture but robots
can dance they're cool and let's just
start the the conversation with this
question of well what is a robot and
when is it that we call it a robot so
question that i have and i think maybe
like it would be a good starter that you
can just go into breakout drones for two
to three minutes just chat about this
and then the question that i guess i
have is think about a hammer if is is a
hammer a robot what do you think
and think about like google or google
home or like siri is that a robot so
what defines a robot and i think that's
just like just the starter to think
about like what is a robot why should we
care about it and go to breakout rooms
two to three minutes we'll come back put
your answers introduce yourself talk to
talk to the people in the breakout room
and then put your answers when you come
back on chat and we'll continue
yes i believe everyone's back all right
yeah so i hope you just met your friends
and other people in the class and yeah
if you have thoughts put it in the chat
we'll look at it later what is a robot
but let's actually continue with our
talk today because again i have a lot of
videos
uh so my plan for today is uh to do a
bunch of things i'm gonna start with a
quick history of robotics where did it
come from why do we care about it
um then i'm gonna spend a bit of time
talking about why you should care about
robots and why should this class care
about robot how are robots related to ai
what is their relationship there
and then i wanted to spend a little bit
of time talking about robotics at
stanford so um what are the research
that's done at stanford uh who are the
faculty who do robotics at stanford just
so you know the faces and you know what
classes to take and kind of like uh what
type of research is done and how you can
get in touch with them
this is probably to the extent that i
can get but if i have time i'm gonna
talk a little bit about some exciting
robotics applications like all the
awesome things that are happening
um also all the not so awesome things
that are happening the fact that robots
are far from perfect or like not there
yet and then if i have time which is
very likely to not be the case
i will talk a little bit about my own
research around interactive robotics
so again the rules of it is at any point
in time interrupt just ask questions
raise your hand like or we'll do that
and we'll go from there
and let's just jump into this quick
history of robotics where does it come
from where does the word robot even
comes from
so the word robot actually is kind of
old it comes from this display from carl
catholic in 1921 the play is called the
rosen's universal robots and it's about
basically this mechanical men that are
built in factory and are supposed to do
work for humans and then they rise
against humans so that's kind of like
the part of it um and and basically it
has a little bit of a dystopian view of
that and and the word these mechanical
men basically are are called robota
which basically means slave or kind of
like labor type work in czech i don't
know if anyone knows czech and i don't
know how accurate that is but that's
basically what i read on wikipedia so i
assume that is that is accurate
um so that was the word robot but
then the word robotic was also first um
introduced by this guy isaac asimov
who is a science fiction writer and then
he came around 1950s and he wrote a
bunch of books about robots and and the
view of it was a little bit nicer it was
a little bit friendlier than this
dystopian view and and he talked about
these different rules of robotics the
robots were there to help humans and
they were supposed to like follow these
different rules so you might you guys
might have heard of these three rules of
robotics by azek asimov so the first one
is that a robot may not injure a human
being or through inaction allow a human
being to come to harm
the second one is a robot must obey the
orders given given it by human beings
except for each or where such orders
with conflict with the first law
and then the last one is a robot must
protect its own existence as long as
such protection does not conflict with
the first and second one okay so kind of
like
this is this is obvious right like you
don't want the robots to to go against
humans and you don't want the robot to
kill itself and and these are kind of
the three rules and and the reason i'm
mentioning this is that people are
coming back to these rules like even
these days like when you're people are
thinking about robots they feel like oh
a robot should try to satisfy these
three laws of robotics and these are
kind of like the core laws that need to
be satisfied
and and the thing about these laws is
sure it is nice but they're kind of
obvious right and actually satisfying
them is the most difficult part and it
doesn't really like go go through that
like like if i'm if i have my robot
running gradient descent on the loss
function how do i define that loss
function accurately so i satisfy these
these rules like that is not a very
obvious thing and then i guess get it in
go go and talk about that
um let me give you an example so let's
say i have rosie the robot that's
supposed to like clean my house or i
have a roomba that roomba is supposed to
clean my house
and let's say i have built this super
nice intricate house of cards okay
any human was helping me clean my house
would know that you shouldn't touch this
house of cards because they spend so
much time and this is so valuable to me
and then you shouldn't touch it you
shouldn't go and clean it but a robot
wouldn't know that why would it like why
would it know what a house of cards is
or like how much energy i've put in in
creating it um so so that is kind of
like the objective function and sure
it's not about harm it might be harming
me it's harming humans uh but but in
general thinking about what should be
the objective that the robot should
satisfy what should the reward function
be we'll be talking about mdps in a
couple of weeks and we'll be talking
about reward functions what should the
reward function be is actually a very
difficult problem this is an active area
of research trying to understand what
are the human preferences what are the
things that humans actually want robotic
agents to do around them and then at the
same time what does the robot think
those preferences are there's a mismatch
between that there's always going to be
a mismatch between that and that
mismatch how harmful is that going to be
how unsafe is it that the robot doesn't
know everything
and and you might ask well why don't you
just like write that as an objective
that hey robot don't go and destroy
doris's house apart
oh that's perfectly fine but the thing
is
like it is really hard to write out all
these specifications all these
properties that we would want to satisfy
in the world because there's just so
much context so much information in the
world and humans just know that like as
they grow up like they learn and they
know that and robots wouldn't
necessarily know that and you might say
that's just data so let's just learn
through that a lot of people agree with
that a lot of people disagree with that
it's still like a point of debate that
is that just data like i just need to
like show more things so the robot knows
house of cards are important to yourself
like that's also an another being but in
general the point of this slide is hey
these rules of uh
uh asymmetry these rules that are put
out there they're not that obvious to
satisfy sure i can say don't kill humans
but it's not like really obvious how i
write out like what does it mean not
harming humans
and the second point i want to make here
is that even that is still under
question then not harming humans it's
actually not obvious to everyone that we
shouldn't use robots not harm humans
which is a little bit silly in my
opinion but i'm just talking about
everyone's opinion here
so like if you think about if you think
about like our defense or other other
countries defense right like uh people
use these things called autonomous
weapon systems which are basically like
you can have drones that can detect
targets and shoot at them you can have
detail autonomous weapon systems these
are commonly referred to laws
by laws and lethal autonomous weapon
system basically and there it's a big
question should we use these should we
not use this when can we use like we
thought autonomous weapon systems and
and yeah it's not like it is here it's
not a thing that's science fiction it's
actually a thing that uh our like
basically u.s defense has it like like
the whole like all over different
countries have some version of this
and and the question is like yeah if we
don't use it like other countries might
use it and how do we think about um like
using or not using these systems like
how do we put a ban event on it what
does a ban on it mean
um and there's a lot of um debate around
this start russell who's a faculty at uc
berkeley and he also features a either
he is he's basically a proponent of
banning or fully banning and with
autonomous weapon systems and he has a
lot of interesting talks around this we
will talk about this a little bit more
toward um like in in the conclusion
lecture but this is also something i
wanted to mention because it could be an
interesting topic to talk to tino about
next week like when you think about laws
and regulating these things how does how
does the regulation how do the
revelations like work and make sense
so yeah so even like not harming humans
which is what isaac
said like that is still like even under
question here like it's not clear if
that is what we want to do
but okay let's go back to the history of
robotics like why do we have robotics
when did it start so around like 50s and
60s um we had a lot of excitement around
ai right so person was talking about ai
last week talking about the history of
ai and that was the time that there was
a ton of excitement and even touring
turing has this paper where in the paper
he writes the best thing we can do is to
build a robot with tv cameras for its
eyes and motors for its legs and have it
run around the countryside and learn
from the world
so this is from back in the day like
touring time and this is what he was
thinking and like even in the same like
in in the same paper later in that paper
turing says well this is too difficult i
don't want to deal with like this
physical interaction with the
countryside so instead maybe we should
focus on the problem of intelligence
maybe we should focus on ai and that is
how like the next six 50 years was all
about ai and building good ai systems
and there was a lot around robotics too
i like sure like robotics also has seen
a lot of advances since 50s
but a lot more has happened in the ai
side of things just because the robotics
side was so difficult
um an example of that is thinking about
a big blue which basically won its first
game against the world champion for
chess in 1996 and it was doing like
amazing intelligence right they had an
intelligence being able to like win at
this game of chess but the thing that
was happening was that the chess pieces
were moved by humans because that was so
difficult like grasping is still so
difficult when you think about like a
robot trying to actually like move these
pieces and and that was not solved like
in 1996 in any race at all yeah
all right so
when did the first robot comes i've been
talking about this history and and like
the question is okay so what was the
first robot out there the first
intelligent robot so the first
intelligent robot was shaky i have a
video of it here uh it's kind of like a
five minute video so it's a little bit
of a long video but let's just watch it
i think it has a lot of interesting
history in it
shaky was the world's first mobile
intelligent robot embodying numerous
breakthroughs in artificial intelligence
robotics computer vision navigation and
other research areas
the robot was developed from 1966 to
1972 by sri international then called
stanford research institute
and its legacy and impact are still very
much alive today shaky is really the
great grandfather of things like
self-driving cars and even military
drones the hardware was really pretty
primitive
but the software architecture and the
software algorithms are what changed the
world i think we all thought we were
doing really interesting stuff so it
didn't really uh dawn on us that we were
doing anything special shaky established
a position about
what we should be thinking about as
possible as feasible
to understand why shaky is so important
we have to go back to 1966 and we have
to understand where ai research was at
that time
well you have to remember that it was
pretty much of a a green field which
nikki started
all over the country and even outside of
the united states people were beginning
to build the components to artificial
intelligence nobody had tried at the
time that shaky was launched to
integrate all the components of ai and
robotics into a single
uh
moving vehicle that could reason about
the world could sense the world around
it and could take actions prior to 1966
there were no robots or at least
non-intelligent ones
[Music]
the concept of an intelligent robot was
limited to the realm of fiction you will
meet a charming character in the robot
always at your service when you read the
title of the original proposal it was
something like a mobile automaton for
reconnaissance
and the reason we called it an automaton
was because until shaking you couldn't
go to a funding agency and say i want
money to make a science fiction kind of
device so we needed name and finally
charlie
in his inimitable fashion said
it shakes like hell when it moves let's
just call it shaky
key components of shaky's hardware were
a tv camera to observe its environment
an antenna radio link
bump detectors and a push bar to move
objects
my role was mainly get the images and
get uh whatever coordinates they needed
to determine where they were and uh
you know extract the information from
the image i remember when i first saw it
gee that looks like a dishwasher
on wheels while charming shaky wasn't
impressive for its looks
it was the ai and programming
advancements that made it famous
we structured shaky software in four
distinct layers
and that was the first time the layered
architecture was used for robots
chicky's pioneering software
architecture paved the way to a new era
of ai and robotics the sri team later
developed flaky a research robot that
demonstrated fuzzy logic and
goal-oriented behavior
then came centabots one of the earliest
projects in swarm robotics where 100
autonomous robots demonstrated the
ability to map a complex area
collaboratively
i like how it's code that isn't just
turning numbers into other numbers you
get to see the thing come to life right
next to you
shaky also inspired research in natural
language-based interactions leading to
the popular speech-based technologies
that we use today
shakey's breakthrough in computer vision
is now used to help drivers stay in
their lanes
and every time you get driving
directions on your phone or navigation
system you are benefiting from the a
star navigation algorithm first invented
for shaky
even nasa's mars exploration rovers use
navigational techniques that were first
launched with shaky
the future is things like potentially
having uh teams of autonomous aircraft
that could go out for example and do
firefighting and doing this either fully
autonomously or potentially in tandem
with human piloted aircraft that can go
out and work with them collaboratively
shaky now resides in the computer
history museum visible to hundreds of
thousands of visitors annually
and in 2017 shaky was honored with an
ieee milestone achievement award
the shaken milestone's important because
first of all shaky is the world's first
mobile intelligent robot
in addition
this is the first ieee milestone in
areas of either robotics or artificial
intelligence
looking back more than 50 years after
the shaky project began it's inspiring
to see how one small team can make such
an impact
how one ambitious idea continues to
benefit our lives
how one robot changed the world
we didn't realize i think any of us what
the significance of this was we knew we
were the first but nobody knew where it
was going and i don't think any of us
would have predicted
what happened
shaky planted the flag way out there
it's a model of the kind of ambitious
projects that we should be looking at in
the future
all right so that was
shaky's video this is actually the yeah
and the computer history museum uh down
the road so when things open up like i
suggest going there and seeing shaky
there
um cool so that was my quick history of
robotics um
any questions
thumbs up just feel free to ask
for
later and
so uh in the next part what i'd like to
do is i'd like to talk a little bit
about how is this related to some of the
topics that we are we're learning
through this class so how are robots in
general like using ideas around ai and i
want to spend a little bit of time on
that
so
if you think about robotics there's this
common architecture that is usually used
for robots
um it's not it's more under question
these days but back in the day actually
like this was the architecture that a
lot of robots tend to use which is the
sensing planning and acting architecture
and then looping that right so so you
sense the world you watch the world you
perceive the world you do perception
and then from that you try to plan
on what to do next that is where the
intelligence lies
and then after that you just act you
execute that plan
and then once you've acted like you can
go back and sense plan and act again and
that's a very common architecture that
most robots do use and then these days
people are thinking about a more
intertwined relationship between sense
plan and act for example uh you
shouldn't just sense the world for the
sake of sensing right like sensing needs
to be active so there's this area called
active perception which is about the
fact that i only sense the parts i care
about and i need to act on and and we
should have like this intertwined
relationship between acting and sensing
uh or there's another paradigm these
days that basically tries to go from
images to to actuation and and kind of
like skip that planet
uh part of it by by replacing by
replacing it by neural networks right so
if i have a machine learning system and
i start from images can i get directly a
control on my robot
that's another paradigm i'll talk about
that a little bit actually in this
section but let's just consider this
this type of paradigm of sensing
planning and acting
and in this class starting next week
we're going to first talk about search
and actually as you heard in the video
uh we're going to talk about algorithms
like ai star that's actually something
that we will we will discuss next week
and ai start was introduced for shaky
right like the point of it it's actually
like an extension of dijkstra's
algorithm and it does have a bunch of
heuristics and it's fairly fast and it
was introduced for for things like
robots moving around and navigating
around today we do use a lot of sampling
based type techniques so the algorithm
that you see here running is this
algorithm called rrt star which is
similar to a star to some extent but
it's more of a sampling based algorithm
creating this tree this dense tree and
navigating along along the right lines
of tree so so the type of things we will
be talking about next week search
actually falls a bunch like in planning
for robots right like when you're
planning for robots you should think
about searching in that space how do you
get from one location space to another
location or how do we get from one robot
configuration to another robot
configuration
following search the week after we're
going to talk about mvps and games right
mvps or markup decision processes
basically the idea there is the world
has uncertainty and we should actually
model those probabilities and
uncertainties and that commonly shows up
when you think about robots interacting
with each other or with the world in
general right like when you have dynamic
environments around you when you have a
self-driving car driving right next to
other cars right that that you can model
that as an mvp and similarly if you
think about this interaction with
another intelligent agent you can model
that as a game and then we will be
discussing that in a couple of weeks and
these ideas show up a lot in robotics so
here uh the video on the left basically
shows two robots that are trying to
coordinate with each other uh and what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to move this rod together but the
interesting thing is that they're
decentralized they don't talk to each
other and they have different
observabilities so the robot in the
front can see the the
books here and the robot in the back can
only see the boxes and just because of
the forces and the feel of the forces
they can understand what the other agent
is doing they can learn what the other
agent's policy is and coordinate with
that agent to do this collaborative type
of maneuver
here's another example uh this is also
from
my lab so uh here what we're looking at
is we're looking at two robots playing
your hockey um and and here we are again
like having this paradigm this game
theoretic paradigm of two robots trying
to coordinate with each other there's a
bit of more learning happening here so
the robots are trying to again learn the
policy of the other agent or
representation of the policy of the
other robot
and based on that like kind of trick the
other agent or influence the other agent
and win this air hockey game
so okay so mvps and games pretty much
show up for any type of interactive
systems and as robots are leaving
factory floors they have more and more
interactions with people or with other
agents and they're super useful again
for for the planning part of robotics
we will see bayesian networks
immediately after that asian networks
again are super useful when it comes to
things like mapping and estimation uh so
here there's this algorithm called
simultaneous localization and mapping
slam
and basically the idea of it is when you
go to this new environment and you don't
know anything about this new environment
you're going to sample points and based
on that you're going to create a map and
navigate yourself around it and estimate
where you are so a lot of ideas around
bayesian networks shows up here uh
actually in one of the homeworks uh
we're going to look at uh things like
particle filters and things like state
estimation
and and based on that
how
how do we use ideas from bayesian
networks uh to do better estimation of
where we are where other agents are and
again that is super useful for any
robotic system that tries to like do
anything in the world basically okay
all right so a lot of that was around
planning uh logic is also another topic
we will discuss in this class it is not
as much used in robotics but it does
show up at various places so here this
is actually a work by chris gazitz group
uh and um
this is called
ltl mop
uh which is basically a tool and the
idea here is they try to get this robot
navigate the space and go to various
squares here
and while doing that it tries to satisfy
some logical formula so instead of
giving it an objective a loss function
and then doing gradient descent let's
say on that and try to come up with a
policy what this robot does is it gets
that logic formula and based on that it
creates a plan on how to navigate this
space and why would anyone want to do
that well the reason why would anyone
want to do that is if you have that
logic formula you can actually prove
things about this robot you can actually
prove that if it would satisfy the
specification or if it wouldn't satisfy
the specification and again that is very
useful when you think about safety of
let's say autonomous cars right if you
want to prove that your autonomous cars
are safe
you would need to add a little bit of
logic there you would need to think
about how that can be used in planning
and also it also helps with transparency
because there is a smaller gap between
let's say natural language and temporal
logic which is this logical language
that they're using here and that smaller
gap can help us like have a more
transparent and
clear idea of what the robot is doing
here okay
all right so that was all planning and
all the topics that we are discussing in
this class
we are currently talking about machine
learning a common place that machine
learning shows up in robotics is on the
sensing side of things so you sense the
world and based on that you you perceive
the role so
perception and vision is is a big part
of robotics and uh a lot of that is done
using machine learning these days right
so so you have a machine learning
network that basically tries to do
object recognition and activity
prediction of what other objects around
you are doing uh or basically like who's
the owner of the car in this case i
think
um
and what are the other objects around us
and things of those forms so that's a
very common place that machine learning
shows up in robotics and the sensing and
perception side of things
and you might ask about this acting part
well what goes in the acting part so
it's not just ai that shows up in
robotics a bunch of other fields also
show up in robotics specifically control
theory and optimization is kind of like
the core of this acting component of
this architecture of sense plan and act
um and and basically the idea is you
might again have an objective like
following a trajectory and you actually
want to put the right control the right
accelerations and fraud on the steering
angle on your autonomous car in this
case and get your autonomous car
navigators
here
and a lot of that a core of that is
actually done using ideas around control
theory more recently people have been
using ideas around machine learning here
too so like adding ideas around deep
learning uh for actually planning and
getting the car to to navigate in this
space
so those are some of the core ideas as i
mentioned earlier there are some other
paradigms of the sense planning act
one specific paradigm which i think is
pretty interesting is to use machine
learning to do kind of what is all of
the sense plan and act by by trying to
learn from humans
so so this is commonly referred to as
learning from demonstrations or
imitation learning and the idea of it is
if i just watch how humans do things
then from that i can just directly
figure out what their objective was or
what their policy is
and then the idea has been around since
like 2000s in the area of robotics
the work on the left that i want to show
is actually like this idea directly
being being applied um to robotics this
is work that peter rubio and andrew ing
did in 2004 at stanford um and basically
the idea is um
there are basically these helicopters
that before then um it was really hard
to fly them by just using control like
by just using like ai and control it was
actually just really hard to to to fly
them
and then there are these pilots that can
fly these helicopters just much more
easily much more simply and and
basically the idea is uh could we use
that here uh to get this horizontal fly
in this space so this is
and by watching a human pilot learn to
fly it then learns to fly by itself
and so what it does is watch the person
fly and then um they'll try to fly the
same stunt movements by itself and maybe
try a few times until instead of nails
and what you're seeing is the end result
of this machine learning process called
apprenticeship
so that was this idea of apprenticeship
learning where kind of like for the
first time like people were able to fly
these quadcopters autonomously
but by learning from human pilots by
learning from human experts and that
idea has been around in research and
people in general have been thinking
about how we can learn from humans how
can we get robots to act in the world by
directly learning from humans but not
just from demonstrations but also from
things like asking their preferences or
language instructions uh so in my lab
actually we're doing
a lot of work in this domain where we're
looking at preference-based learning and
actively basically querying people for
what their preference trajectory is and
in order to basically get a robot to
play some version of mini golf here like
targeting for one of these balls and get
the robot to actually hit the ball
correctly so it gets in the right goal
and that's kind of exciting because you
can learn from all sorts of human
feedback right you can learn from
demonstrations comparisons um language
and from that you are able to basically
get a robot to an interesting type of
maneuver
another place that machine learning
shows up is again like by combining this
sensing plan and act into one giant box
right like starting from visual data and
once you start from visual data can you
try to directly get actions on your
robots and and this idea of robot
learning has been very popular in recent
years um this is work from berkeley from
2015
where basically the idea is to get the
robot to just try out things and then
from that from these images and and kind
of joint angles of what the robot tries
from that it learns how to achieve the
task and how to do the test it's a very
data intensive type of process but
there's a lot of excitement because you
can achieve things that you weren't able
to achieve before
and we have seen a lot of advances in
machine learning uh when it's applied to
let's say nlp and vision places where we
have a lot of data we don't have that
much data in robotics but if that is the
bottleneck then maybe we can create an
arm farm kind of like this this image
this video here
and and create an arm form and basically
just collect lots of lots of data of
robots basically like navigating in this
space moving randomly inside of this box
and from that learn how to just grasp
any object that we see
um this is actually worked by uh google
robotics so google x has a sub group
google robotics that does a lot of work
on robot learning a lot of interesting
work
and yeah like very intensive you need to
very compute intensive
but lots of excitement around this idea
of directly learning actions uh from
sensing data okay
all right
so
let me move to oh okay so so those were
all the things i wanted to say on how ai
is used in robotics but ai is not the
only thing that is used in robotics um
there are a bunch of other things like
as you can as you've probably noticed
robotics spans a bunch of different
different departments
for example you see robotics in
mechanical engineering and that has a
very different view of robotics and and
that view is usually focused on design
and co-design which is a super important
problem right so if you're thinking
about building an arm or building a hand
that needs to do very precise
manipulation what type of sensors you're
using how are you building this system
like those are all really good questions
like how do we make sure that you build
a prosthetic that is not too heavy and
it's also comfortable and is also very
safe for the person to use for walking
like these are all really great
questions that are usually like design
questions that are super important in
robotics
um another reason that this is important
is that there's a whole new area around
co-design which basically says well for
whatever hardware we pick there's going
to be some ai algorithm but if i change
that hardware my ai algorithm is going
to change and if i change my ai
algorithm like that could run on a
different hardware very differently so
can we design both of these at the same
time we design what our robot should
look like and what algorithm should run
should run on them kind of at the same
time or can we have reconfigurable
robots and a lot of excitement around
this area in general when you think
about design and co-design of these
systems
i just want to show a few other cool
designs that are out there that are very
impressive
um one design that i want to show is
this robot on the left
this robot on the left is is a dynamic
integrity structure so what it is is it
basically has a bunch of rigid rigid
links like these guys
and then these links are connected by
things that are kind of like ropes
and it's kind of like a funny structure
but the interesting thing about it is it
is shock resistant so like nasa really
cares about this robot because landing
robots on the surface of mars is really
difficult
but if i just drop this robot like
nothing happens to it and it can just
roll around and continue moving forward
which is again a very interesting design
for something that you don't want to to
break because robots in general are
pretty rigid and and this robot is very
flexible so there's a lot of interest in
basically building robots that are
softer that are less frigid that are
flexible and this is an example of that
another robot that i think is kind of
fun i'll show this a little bit later a
video of it um there's this robot from
stanford this is from mark kotkowski's
lab and it's called stickybot it's it's
basically a robot that has
kind of gekko-like hands so it's hands
are inspired by like hands of gecko and
having like these suction cups and
because of that it can climb up like
walls and really like slippery like
slopes um which is again a very
interesting design
another design that i find super
interesting is uh this inflatable snake
robot this is from allison nakamura's
lab again in the mechanical engineering
at stanford and the idea here is that
this robot can inflate itself as it goes
through different different parts of the
environment so it might be really
difficult for example to go through go
through this hole but like as the robot
is inflating it's actually making its
way through different like kind of
narrow spaces and getting to various
areas um of the space
this can also be used inside of our body
for example when we are doing like more
intelligence type of endoscopy like we
can actually send some of these robots
inside of the body and navigate a little
bit better inside of our body for
robotic surgery for things like
endoscopies and so on
i can take any questions now actually
about any of this
uh a quick question so you mentioned
that robotic counseling stuff like
computer revision machine learning
working by the system so what do you
recommend for people who want to go into
the field
uh do you study all
control of their novels or is there
was a role
yeah that's a very good question yeah so
it kind of seems like a giant thing
right like because it incorporates like
everything and and the field of robotics
in general when you go to the
conferences it is interesting because
you see people from all these different
fields but but they're coming together
for the same problem but not the same
technique which is which is a very
interesting kind of fields to be in but
now at the end of the day like everyone
just like focuses on their expertise and
then brings it together as part of a
team so for example robotics and cs like
at stanford i'll be talking about that
actually a little bit there's a lot
focused on developing ai algorithms
developing algorithmic side of this but
they don't really like to as much on on
the design side but robotics in the
mechanical engineering is very focused
on building new designs new structures
and yeah we do have a lot of joint
projects where we use new designs and
try to develop new algorithms for them
and lots of collaboration in these
different fields so it is a very
interdisciplinary field but yeah as i
said it might seem too large it's not
that large at the end of the day
everyone focuses on the thing that
they're actually like very interested in
or the same goal of building robots
i have a question
what subfields of robotics would be
really great to go into a startup for
right now
uh so to start it right is that what you
yeah so that's a good question to ask um
yeah so i think there's a lot of
excitement around autonomous driving
right so and autonomous driving these
days is very focused on like vision and
machine learning and control theory so
like those three kind of like
backgrounds are commonly used in
autonomous driving but beyond autonomous
driving i think um again a lot of big
companies are using them so it's not
necessarily startups but beyond that
yeah so people are very interested in
domestic robots these days right
actually like getting robots inside
people's houses which wasn't the case
like a few years back even right like we
have robots functioning very well on
factory floors but having robots in our
homes is a big problem and there were
some startups that weren't very
successful so it's kind of like a
kind of like an edgy area to to be in
but i think there's a lot of excitement
there like uh home automation like
things like kind of next generation
chromebooks or other things that we can
have in in homes and again for that i
think like a lot of these systems are
using machine learning ai in general so
that is again like a huge like
background that you would want to have
but the design is pretty important there
so like with the type of like hardware
design that you use there is actually
super important
yeah and healthcare like like kind of
like thinking about robotics being used
in healthcare in hospitals and things of
those form i think that is also a very
exciting area
thank you
wanna ask a question
uh yeah so he's kind of like follow up
so he's about like a robotics like
research because right now like
you know like after you said previously
be like there's a lot of things like
happening in ai stuff and also like
there's also like something happening
control theory so
is there any research kind of like
moving these two things together because
uh for my undergrad i study also
certainly something like control theory
and also ai because i find out like in
control theory they have like some
really interesting concepts actually
like stability like observability like
all of this
have you so
there are any research like for example
using this concept for example like a
reinforcement learning center
in like learning site apps which is
missing like a stability or like
some concepts like this is there any
research about that yeah there's a lot
of excitement actually around that and i
totally agree with that right there is a
lot of interesting topics in control
theory there are a lot of interesting
topics in ai and machine learning that
are just making their ways into robotics
and the two communities um at first
there was a little bit of like clashes
between them i would say but now i think
there's a lot of like coming together
and trying to combine those ideas
there's a new conference called learning
for uh dynamics and control of what we
see and the whole point of that is
actually bring in learning people and
control people together to try to use
the same ideas yeah lots of research
trying to bring learning and control
together and i think that is actually
the right direction because as you said
lots of interesting ideas in dynamics
and control and i think a lot of those
ideas could be used as prior structures
uh that could be put on learning based
systems so when you're let's say
training a neural network you can bring
in structure that you know about the
system that comes from control theory
let's say
[Music]
i had a question
sure
sure i was wondering you know you talked
about um armed forms and
you know collecting lots of data do you
feel like the field
is more data limited or more algorithm
and learning limited i think about when
i learned to drive
it wasn't that way it should have been
more data but it wasn't it was just
maybe um a couple weeks of practice
um and then i was
ready that's a very good point so um i
think it's a combination i do think the
field is very data limited and it's
interesting because yeah when you learn
to drive right you spend a couple of
weeks but you have seen cars drive right
next to you like the learning by
observation which is like a very
interesting type of learning you're not
learning by doing you're learning by
like observing other people like driving
right next to you
uh and that has so much information in
it it's kind of the same problem that i
mentioned earlier with the house of
cards example right like your autonomous
car doesn't know that it's important but
like you would know that you have so
much context like in the world and
because of that like i think like the
issue is specifically for autonomous
cars is some of these corner cases so
like driving on a highway like that's
like solved right
the issue is like some of these corner
cases that it hasn't seen yet in the
data and maybe more data will solve that
so i think more data is definitely a
problem i think we can still do better
on our algorithms too but data is still
like i would say that's the higher kind
of issue at least in autonomous driving
i would say
on the data side um do you feel that
synthetic data could be something that
would be useful for machine learning
applications or is that something that's
kind of like gonna always be a fantasy
i think it's super useful right like if
you can create near accident driving
scenarios and driving and then kind of
train your car in those settings and
then just generate that automatically
that would be super useful so then you
don't need to wait forever to see like
in your accident driving scenario on the
vehicle i think one issue there is like
this simulation to reality gap which is
which is a big problem specifically for
robotics but i do think generation of
data is important yeah
uh hi so i have a question regarding the
deterministic of
robotics for example uh in terms of
machine regulations my government
usually requires that actions of a
machine to be
state and manufacturers of the machine
sometimes responsible for these actions
there is a machine learning base or deep
learning based algorithms uh they are
statistical by uh by definition so
how could
how do we define the responsibility of
the um manufacturer of the machines and
if there's artists that accidentally
comes by autonomous driver uh who should
be responsible in this case yeah that's
very good that's a very good question
for tino next week actually so very good
question um yeah so the first point that
you made that yeah like like all the
laws are about about deterministic
systems that's actually not like always
the case so for example michael
kochenderfer in the aeronastro
department he has done a lot of work
around palm vps that actually run on
like aircraft systems so there's this
acas excuse system which is basically
unmanned like aircraft
like like all of the all the motions
landing and taking off and all of that
is done in kind of like an online
setting but the system is small it's
upon vp which with like a few states and
all that and you can verify everything
about it so there's a lot of interesting
rules around verification and validation
in this space and even if it is not
deterministic you can't still like
verify it uh so the small palm bp for
example partially observable markup
decision process you won't see that in
the class if you're interested in that
topic take michael's class but when it
comes to neural networks yeah we don't
really have that much guarantees around
it and
there's a lot of again discussion here
so some people are taking the route of
trying to prove things and trying to
verify neural networks clark barrett is
someone in the cs department who does a
lot of work on verification of neural
networks again we are limited in the
size there so we can't have giant neural
networks there
another kind of perspective on this is
giving these statistical guarantees
right like if my autonomous car is safer
than humans statistically maybe that is
good enough and we are okay with some
number of accidents some number of times
maybe you would be okay with that
um and some of it is yeah like
acceptance issues too right like the
first like aircraft that were out there
probably not safe probably people were
okay with that and the number of deaths
were like higher right and and i think
there's a little bit of that acceptance
issue for how this is going to pan out
but it is actually a very good question
of how are we going to regulate and who
is going to be at plane uh one can take
tesla's approach and be like a human is
always in control so if anything happens
it was it was a human's fault which is
kind of like a weird type of type of
approach i would say um it's not
necessarily the safest way to go uh but
yeah i don't honestly have good answers
for this something to ask tino next week
i have a question with regards to the
co-design
so you mentioned about the hardware and
the ai algorithm needs to go hand in
hand
so
for example the self-driving car has to
make you know the algorithms have to
make
a quick decisions with the real time
change in the environment
and if the algorithms take a long time
to run and i know the hardware wise
there are a variety of uh
ways the algorithm can be put on let's
say on a gpu or on other aspects so
would you please uh
are there any uh pointers towards how
these two
go hand in hand and what is the
best so i was more thinking about it in
an offline kind of fashion right so in
an offline kind of fashion you can have
like a fancy algorithm that does like
everything like that has that takes a
lot of compute let's say for a hardware
that is very simple or you can kind of
like increase complexity of your
hardware and on the other hand have a
really simple algorithm that runs on it
one place that so i wasn't really
thinking about the online aspect of it
which you're right like yeah they're
like running at different frequencies so
how could they work together uh one
example of that is an assistive robotics
assistive teleoperation when you're
using a joystick to control a robot arm
this is something that you work on
commonly and you can make the hardware
very interesting very intricate like use
haptic devices and then be able to
control things like much easier on the
other hand you can have a hardware
that's really simple so for example
there are these sip and puff devices uh
that a lot of patients with disabilities
use and it's a very simple device you
can only like sip and puff like that's
the only thing you can do but then the
algorithm that's underneath needs to be
like much more complicated to be able to
capture what that what that zip-and-puff
means so so that's kind of like one
place that this interplay between
hardware and soft hardware and algorithm
really shows up
all right thank you
guys yeah let me okay so let me continue
a little bit um and then i'll stop at
the end of this section and i can take
more questions too
um after that i kind of want to show
some of these applications too at some
point this section is small so the
robotics at stanford one yeah so okay so
we talked about all of these we talked
about the history um
robotics said stanford had an
interesting history too so it does have
like an old history uh here's a video
that i kind of just wanted to show for
fun uh this is a video from usama kitube
slab and sam always has the best videos
um he has these two robots juliet and
romeo the other fun thing in this video
for me is lots of these people are like
faculty now or like very famous in the
field so it's kind of fun to see them as
grad students at stanford so yeah this
is like oliver brock um this is gates if
you like look at it closely it is first
floor updates it hasn't changed much
uh this robot is still on the first
floor of gates so if you get a chance to
go there it is still like sombra
um and yeah like this is basically
getting this robot helper to help you do
various sort of things like move objects
for you um they have basically two of
these let me move forward a little bit
so it helps you like carry objects and
things of those forms it's very old
robot and some of these concepts that
you study like now even like thinking
about interaction between humans like
they were actually like they were
thinking about this back in the day this
is collaborative transport these robots
are not decentralized they do actually
have a centralized control but they're
compliant so meaning that they're not
rigid right like if you move it like
they also get moved
um
yeah so i think and then later on
there's this video of dancing uh with
romeo so again it's compliant and it
kind of moves around you and all that so
this is some old videos from stanford
robotics some more recent video of
videos of stanford robotics and
successes i guess
is um
about the star for grand challenge so um
it's not that recent it's from 2005. so
darpa grand challenge was this
competition that darpa put out and
basically it was a competition that was
trying to get researchers to work on
autonomous driving
and this was um this was basically um
the competition in 2005 where sebastian
thrawn uh was heading the stanford team
and
stanley
was uh the vehicle and actually won the
competition
[Music]
in case you don't recognize it that is a
volkswagen tourette
into the finish line configuration
ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls
it's been done
[Applause]
so that is stanley passing the finishing
line after this actually sebastian
throne left
stanford and joined google and started
the google self-driving car uh groupter
now waymo and yeah lots of advances in
autonomous driving since then uh but
this was kind of one of the big
successes of stanford robotics winning
basically uh this uh darpa grand
challenge which is very exciting but in
general robotics at stanford uh kind of
falls into a bunch of different
departments so in computer science uh
here are some of the faculty i just
wanted to show their faces so
uh you know who they are and you can
take classes from them later on and
things of those form so uh usama kiteb
i've already showed a lot of videos from
his lab i have one more from his lab
that i'll show later
uh and someone does a lot of work around
field robotics meaning that i'm gonna
send robots to places that humans
haven't seen before and see what happens
which is like really exciting
um then we have ken salisbury who does a
lot of work around like helper robots
and and building systems that can
actually help people sylvia does a lot
of work around vision and robotics so
he's primarily a vision faculty but he
is thinking about that intersection of
vision robotics and some of the more
recent um people have joined including
myself jeanette and chelsea so does a
lot of work around manipulation i am
personally very interested in
interaction so when you think about
multi-agent interaction or interaction
with humans and chelsea does a lot of
work around robot learning metal
learning and things of those form
in addition to some of these faculty
there are some other folks in the cs
department who do a lot of work that is
related to robotics so again fei-fei
does quite a bit of work and vision but
also is interested in robotics that
intersection and then karen liu and
jojen wu both of them recently joined
stanford and they do a ton of work
around physical simulation graphics
things of those form uh and that has a
lot of relations to to building robots
that can work with um like deformable
objects and things of those form
and some folks who used to do robotics i
guess are andrew and sebastian so
i showed a video of andrew's learning
from demonstration work earlier the the
flying
video of the helicopter and then
sebastian has done a lot of work in
autonomous driving
uh they're both kind of around so andrew
andrew does a lot of work in healthcare
these days lesten comes in he's an
adjunct faculty now
outside of computer science you still
have a lot of robotics faculty so in the
aero astro department we have grayscale
max schrager and marco pavone and
michael kochendurfer i mentioned
michael's work around aircraft systems
earlier so building these acasu systems
and and trying to prove properties
around them they all do a lot of work
around drones and quadcopters and
helicopters things of those form
multi-agent systems and being able to
get guarantees and talk about risk
and finally in mechanical engineering we
have a good number of faculty allison
nakamura sean former mark otkowski steve
collins and monroe kennedy a lot of the
like al most of almost all of them do
quite quite interesting work here on
design too so building systems that are
actually like interesting and useful the
the sticky bot that i showed earlier was
from mark slap
the snake robot was from from allison's
lab sean does a lot of interesting work
at the intersection of robotics and hci
so if that is something you're
interested in you should check you
should check out like what these faculty
teach and and all that so that was kind
of my very quick robotics at stanford
type of overview let me spend another
five minutes showing some of these
applications and maybe after that i'll
take questions for the last five minutes
and i have a seven minute video
that i'll just leave after the class for
you guys to watch it's like a 50-year
like history of robotics which is kind
of fun
all right so i wanted to show you
basically generally some exciting
applications of robotics and i actually
had a hard time classifying it because i
think classifying them
are can they can be classified with
different axes and and it was hard to
classify them but i ended up classifying
them into three main groups
the first group is bio-inspired robots
which is basically let's look at biology
and try to build robots that are useful
so it's a lot of interesting design goes
there
another interesting direction is soft
robotics meaning that hey i'm going to
build systems that that use soft
material so they're the integrity
structure was an example of that so
they're flexible they're soft they're
not rigid they're not going to break
i'm not going to actually talk much
about soft robots but i'm going to talk
about manipulating soft objects which is
a very difficult algorithmic question
and then finally if i have time i will
talk a little bit about domestic and
interactive robots which is something
that i think is really exciting like
this interaction with humans is
something that you should really care
about as robots are basically starting
to interact with us
all right so bioinspired robots this is
more of an like interesting design
question so from kind of early on
everyone was interested in humanoids
because you want robots to look like
humans for some reason so there's a lot
of work around humanoids and building
robots that look like humans that is
they have two arms and two hands and two
legs and a face
but at some point people realize robots
don't need to look like humans and they
started looking at the nature in general
and and then started thinking about
generally bioinspired robots right there
are a lot of a lot of animals that can
get to places that humans can't and can
be built robots that are similar to them
and and
another interesting topic that shows up
here specifically under humanoids is
this idea of walking so people have been
obsessed with walking for years now and
it's an interesting problem like if you
want to build a robot that walks kind of
like humans that is still very difficult
like all walking robots have like weird
gates and they don't really like walk
like human like and when they do they're
just super inefficient like humans are
just amazing at walking and that's in
general very active area of research
trying to get robots to walk and why do
we care about that well first off it's
an interesting question second like
building exoskeletons building systems
that can help people watch is always an
interest
in this field
so let's look at a few bioinspired
robots i only just want to show a lot of
videos of these systems
so one type of bio-inspired robots is
looking at insects like cockroaches
and try to build robots that kind of act
like cockroaches because they're amazing
at getting through like obstacles and
there's a team at uc berkeley ron
fearings group that basically designs
robots
that are
similar to cockroaches and they go
through places like cockroaches
and the nice thing about it is yeah
they're very agile they go through
things the other thing is they're small
and they can be super fast so you can
have a swarm of these robots get to
places super fast
and another interesting thing about
cockroaches is when they navigate they
use their antennas so that is actually
how they figure out where the ball is
like using the antenna they figure out
they kind of like follow the ball and
and basically people in ron's group have
have been using similar type of ideas to
be able to sense the world and actuate
in this world um and they even build
these robots using origami which is kind
of interesting but it makes sure that
they're small and they're not they don't
take as much battery power and energy
and
and they're kind of like white
let me actually move to this one
the other robot that i showed you a
little bit earlier is the bioinspired
robot is the sticky bot from mark slap
so uh basically if you look at gecko
feet it has these suction cups uh that
it's very very tiny suction cups that
gets attached to glass and because of
that like this robot is using a similar
type of paradigm and it can just like
walk up like really slippery slopes
um
like polish granite
and that is super impressive
thing so lots of cool design going on
here
um
similarly uh i think snake robots and
eel robots are very popular there are a
lot of like links connected to each
other and they can navigate easily this
is an elite robot it's an underwater
robot it does have a camera in the front
and based on that it navigates
uh which is kind of cool
all right
and then this is a
this is a hopper so this is uh basically
a robot again from ron's group uh salto
which is kind of like
jumps around like a bush baby
um it's kind of cool
if if you guys have used things like
mujoku which is a simulation environment
you might see these random animals in
murdocal part of it is roboticists care
really about like different types of
animals like swimming type of motion
hopping and
and that's why those show up in this
mutuco type environment which is a
simulation wise physics simulator that
allows you to train things basically in
simulation
all right so those were those were
generally bioinspired type robots as i
mentioned earlier we've been obsessed
with humanoids so lots of energy and
money goes into building humanoids
um honda actually like spent a lot of
money on building this this robot called
azima
it's walking is kind of weird
[Music]
i am happy to be here with you today
thank you
i'm excited to be here in washington d.c
[Music]
all right i'm gonna cut it there
um but yeah so humanoids have been
really exciting and another place that
actually humanoids show up um is uh
basically um
when you have um
one other example i want to show
basically is sending humanoids type
robots to spaces that you wouldn't be
able to send before so i want to show a
video of uh this robot from usama's
group uh ocean one you some of you might
have seen this video
um this is basically not full humanoid
it does have two arms so you can
teleoperate it and get the robot do
various things
um but it goes underwater to places that
people have not been able to go before
so let's just quickly watch this video
it's kind of like a nice video
it's almost work
[Music]
ocean one is aimed at bringing a new
capability for underwater exploration
the intent here is to have a diver
diving virtually creating a robot that
can be
the
physical representation of the human
if you want a robotic diver that can
have bi-manual capabilities
so it has two hands it has a stereo
vision and the most amazing thing about
it is that
you can feel
what the robot is doing while it's
sitting up on the boat
and this is combining the technology of
haptics that is the idea that we can
reflect the contact forces
it's almost like you are there with the
sense of touch you create a new
dimension of perception
this robot is oil filled it allows us to
take the robot very deep this robot can
go to thousands is this stanford truly a
human-like machine
that is also human-friendly
[Music]
essentially shipwrecked located about 20
miles off the coast of toulon in france
at 100 meters
in the last year we have been working
and getting our robots ready to take on
that expedition
we are going to land on the moon
[Music]
more than 70 percent of the surface of
the planet is water we have a lot of
structures a lot of polar potteries to
monitor
we need to reach down there you can
think about it as a solution
[Music]
that much time i'm going to kind of like
move forward because probably the last
thing i want to show is the walking uh
video and then i'll close it and ask for
questions but yeah like uh in general if
you're interested in underwater robots
kusama does a lot of work around that
he's at stanford he teaches classes talk
to him i think that's a very interesting
direction
uh and then finally i guess the last
video that i can show under this
category is um this idea of walking and
jumping in things of those forms so um
so there's a lot of again excitement
around that and boston dynamics the
first video i showed you guys for the
dancing robot was also from boston
dynamics
um does a lot of work around building
very dynamic robots so they have really
good controllers for these robots uh and
this is atlas
from austin dynamics
jumps
flips even
that is super impressive
and usually roboticists show that one
video of it working and don't talk about
videos of it not working but more
recently people are showing more videos
of things not exactly working so i think
this video it actually it's super
impressive how it recovers because that
is really hard to do in real time
that was a failure so
yeah so okay so lots of excitement
around these areas
i can start taking questions now i'm not
gonna show more videos i have more stuff
to show but let me just like answer a
couple of questions and then i'll just
at the end i took 220 i'll
leave this video up 50 years of robotics
that osama put together and has fun
music
um so any questions
i had a question i was super impressed
by the last video you showed of the
robot doing flips i was wondering it
looked really heavy like it had a lot of
materials and i was wondering if um like
why they chose to equip it with such
materials i i thought you know maybe
using lighter um materials so it could
be easier to jump i was just curious if
you knew um the reason behind uh how
they designed that robot that's a very
good question yeah so i don't know the
details of it because i don't personally
like work too much on uh like walking
and like the design side of things uh
but yeah i actually don't know like what
material they're using they definitely
do consider different types of material
and making sure there's lightweight and
all that but i think there's just a lot
of like joints and a lot of stuff going
on with that robot um if you're
interested to learn more about that yeah
boston check out like boston dynamics
basically website they have all their
other cool robots there
i have a question
um so i was wondering um what's some
examples of state-of-the-art research
involved
both robotics and nlp or language based
ai for example voice activated systems
or related work
yeah there's a lot of excitement around
actually nlp and robotics uh i actually
have a student uh joined between me and
percy which is very exciting this is
like first time doing nlp robotics
together um there's a lot of work around
instruction following so basically just
making an interactive teaching so when
you have a person and a robot at home
like how would the robot learn that you
care about house of cards or you don't
care about house of cards type of type
of a thing so thinking about human robot
interaction a little bit more carefully
than you actually have access to nlp so
so that is one place that it shows up
another place that is a little bit
harder to think about but i think it has
a lot of value is uh thinking about the
large data set
of natural language data that we have
generally like we have a lot of like
text data and from that if you can from
that learn something about context learn
something about how a robot should like
cook an egg like i think that is that is
very interesting too and i haven't seen
that much work around it but again lots
of lots of excitement in that particular
intersection of nlp and robotics
hi i had a question as well
maybe this goes more into the scope of
visual recognition but robots will be
playing a part in this too
so the world unfortunately will always
consist of good factors and evil factors
and for international security purposes
there will be a role if there already is
a rule for robots and autonomous systems
but those same methods can unfortunately
also be used for human rights violations
too how do you build it so that any
technology will always be neutral is its
use that determines what the outcome is
but in the case of human rights
violations how can you build systems so
that
um an authoritarian regime
or what would be the way to using
technology to evade an authoritarian
regime that will have the most best
technology
i've seen some works around how to full
uh facial recognitions
how can technology work against
technology when it's needed and also
serve its purpose
i think it's a tough question
it is a very tough question i refer that
to tino next week specifically but uh in
the case of vision and in the case of
like using ml like in general like
machine learning i think it is much like
much tougher uh in the last lecture i
will talk about this a little bit like
this idea of like fooling like neural
networks there's some recent work around
uh basically showing that you can always
find adversarial examples so this idea
of trying to like safeguard your system
so it doesn't get affected by
adversarial examples is just not going
to work like there's proof uh by
auditioning here and others uh who have
actually shown that you can always find
like basically an adversarial example in
some settings under some distances uh in
the case of robotics um i've been part
of some discussions around this idea of
autonomous weapon systems as i mentioned
earlier um for those discussions
there are discussions on the number of
drones that for example can be purchased
at the same time and things of those
forms a lot of concerns there is
basically autonomous weapon systems
becoming weapon of mass destruction uh
which is kind of scary like as i talk
about it um but yeah like um discussions
around that is what sort of limitations
can be put what sort of regulations can
be put there so like people don't buy
too many drones at the same time and
weaponize it let's say like things of
those forms
but i'm definitely not an expert in this
i refer you to tina hoyler next week
on more details on this
thank you thanks so
much i have a question regarding uh
among all these uh since robotic is such
an integrated subject uh like it
integrates like mechanical engineering
artificial intelligence and also power
management
and also regulations what is that the
biggest limiting factor uh that prevents
robotics from uh like affecting
everyone's life from being like widely
adopted
and by being widely adopted uh they're
still like dealing with uncertainty is
still like so difficult right so like
you have robots in factory floors
confined spaces they can move around so
much easily uh putting it in a world
where humans are just like walking
around it there's so many reasons that
the human could walk around it and like
figuring out what those reasons are can
be really difficult so in general
dealing with uncertainty dealing with in
the case of autonomous driving or
dealing with things like near accident
scenarios that it hasn't seen before uh
all of those like that uncertainty is
like a big factor that's not allowing us
to have robots like out there like
widely used in our everyday lives
so given the current ai technology
mostly are based on learning algorithms
but if you keep doing the learning
algorithm that means you can only like
learn existing behaviors uh so in order
to deal with these uncertainties are
there any efforts to deal with
uncertainties in life or do something
like a self-generated motion or
self-motivated actions from the robots
itself
yeah so yeah definitely yeah so there's
a lot of work around um like actively
generating these scenarios active
learning in this domain so the robot had
but the robot still has some sort of
hypothesis space that it can search in
right so uh like you have a hypothesis
space of things that can happen and
within that you can search um and yeah
so so like there are these things that
are called known unknowns and unknown
unknowns you can't really do much around
unknown unknowns better than like other
than just randomly experiencing them but
for known unknowns yeah definitely like
there's a lot of work on actively
looking for the most informative data i
guess another reason that we don't have
robots widely used is it's such an
integrated system and it's such an
interconnected system so you have like
the best ai algorithm and all of a
sudden your camera fails
like the hardware failure can affect
like there's so many things that can
fail in that pipeline
that makes it just such a difficult
system to debug it's like everything
coming together
so all right so i'm going to just leave
this video on and then at the end of it
i'm going to sign off uh because it's so
fun it has fun music
osama again made this osama is awesome
in making music but if you have more
questions about these things just come
to the office hour and i'll be happy to
answer any questions let's just watch 50
years history of robotics so if you guys
want to sign off sign up to i'll talk to
you later this is seven minutes all
right
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
wow
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
that was kind of long
but kind of fun
so this is for repress 2020
okay
do they still have 30 people oh my god
okay
all right
uh good seeing you all uh that's it
i'll see you at office hours in our next
lecture later bye